[Music]
hey everyone welcome back to our podcast
and this series is called high school
memories my name is sua and I'll be your
host today in this episode we're diving
head first into the world of teen
entrepreneurship join us as we explore
the stories of young entrepreneurs
business ideas and the experiences of
starting a business from scratch to
provide us where their valuable insights
and experiences we have a remarkable
guest joining us today please welcome Mr
Zakia Shabani an entrepreneur with the
wealth of business expertise thank you
for being with us Mr shabon thank you
for having me here today so it's my
pleasure let's kick things off by diving
into your journey could you please share
with our listeners how you embarked on
your entrepreneurial path as a teenager
and what motivated you to take that
buold step as you may know I'm a
journalist for more than 20 years now
and uh I started as you said from
scratch I started as an intern uh for
working for a local
newspaper and I saw there a lot of
possibilities as a young guy uh looking
for the new steps for the future and I
saw that uh being just a journalist is
good it's honorable and it's important
to inform citizens but this was not
import this was not so enough for me and
I saw possibilities of being an
entrepreneur and being a guy who leads
new journalist in the world of business
this mean journalism business and uh
after working for more than 16 years I
started thinking about having my media
business uh involving technology and
involving new ways of broadcasting news
to the citizens making easier for them
to watch read uh read and listen in a
new way as the new technology offers
possibilities for citizens to be
informed seeing that uh you started
journalism as just an intern does it
mean that being an intern helps with
being an entrepreneur uh being an intern
is the first step of being an
entrepreneur so you cannot be a business
person without having an idea of uh what
is the business and what is uh uh what
are your uh goals and uh ways of uh uh
traveling in the into the life or
building a career so it's so important
starting from somewhere and I started
being an intering Co aitor and worked
there for couple of months then I became
a young
journalist and it was important for me
to learn how to write an article how to
gather information and how to inform
citizens and other people interested in
my work so uh for all people starting
somewhere is important and starting as
an intern is the first step of being a
business person in the in every field
this doesn't matter uh if it's
journalism if it's a restaurant or it's
another business but you have to start
somewhere and uh being in intern you
will learn
not just about that work but you will
learn and you will start putting in
place what you have read it in the books
what you have learned from professors
what you have uh seen and being an
intern is time for you to put in place
all the skills and other uh expertise
and start uh start your way of working
and doing
things um by seeing that you were also
in high school and you were a student uh
was it always your dream to be a
journalist or did you have any other
conflicts about your job or your
work uh to be honest journalism was not
my uh field I uh I graduated in business
management and I always wanted to to
work in uh business to work in uh
statistics and other fields that
included math something not uh so good
to hear from students so but uh this was
uh becoming a journalis was something I
always say that was accidentally uh I
started as a intern in Co auditor
uh explaining
uh how figures or translating figures
into the words this was uh something new
working writing about economy articles
so somehow it was completing my dream of
uh uh which included statistics uh
business uh
issues uh financial problems and uh
explaining them to citizens to to the
readers so I worked for uh almost 8
years as economy journalism Co auditor
and this became a dream of having my
My Business Media business
so I'm now owning a business uh living
my dream as a journalist but living my
dream as a business person in media uh
business it is really inspiring to hear
your journey and how you come so far
from an early age see that many students
have their problems about going to
college and having their degrees do you
think it's really just important or is
it necessary to have a degree to start a
business or just be an entrepreneur
starting a business doesn't require any
uh degree any University diploma or
other certificates uh in order to open a
business but requires knowledge and
requires uh uh skills to operate the
business in order to succeed in the in
any field of uh business uh you need
knowledge that cannot be taken and
cannot be one anywhere else but in
schools so in so is important to be
successful and uh to be good graded uh
student so you will you will easily deal
with any obstacle any uh barriers that
you face in U in the daily life during
uh the business operation or any
anything because it's not easy to to
operate with a business uh if you don't
have that kind of knowledge that you get
you get in the school uh it's really
also inspiring I totally agree with your
concept because being a high school
student I also feel um I have
difficulties on my field of studies and
it's not really easy to uh to go into a
field without just knowing something you
need to have um some special
um help or from parents from uh teachers
or anyone in particular but uh let's get
back into your work your business so is
it uh difficult to finance a new
business without any income and if so
how do you overcome it uh one of the the
steps uh beside the uh business plan or
the part of the business uh plan it's uh
how to finance the business so having an
idea is not enough but that idea has to
be uh to we worked on it and to become a
real business so a lot of people have
ideas a lot of people dream having a
business but not all of them succeed to
build a business so first of all you
need a business plan that includes uh uh
the ways of financing it or the ways or
the steps how to put the the idea on the
work and how to put that idea uh the way
that the business will uh succeed
so finances
are the the core or the most important
part of starting a business and U not
everyone have have uh wealthy wealthy
parents
or monies uh that are there so you can
grab them and start a business but you
supposed to start a business from
scratch and you don't have any money so
you
have uh from my from my point of view
you have two two ways of uh generating
those money needed to start a business
one way is uh going to the bank with a
good business plan uh and that uh
guarantees that this business will
succeed and ask for money and another
way is asking your relatives your people
you know the people you trust and the
people who trust you with a good
business plan again that that guarantees
that this business will succeed and ask
them for the money so for uh me I was uh
asking uh people that I knew and who
trusted me that I will be a successful
one in this business and they gave me
money to start this business so don't
hesitate uh if you fail is nothing keep
failing until you succeed thank you for
your incredible words I also agree with
this because not everyone has
generational wealth it doesn't just come
to you as many people think they do it's
seeing nowadays is really incredible how
Banks and how people have uh have made
not just with technology but have uh
made this advancement to to uh be able
to take money and just uh just as a loan
and give it back because many people
need it and they may use it for
different uh business
opportunities is it um being not just
being a business owner but uh having an
organizational structure how does your
organizational structure work um media
business is completely different from
other uh businesses uh it's important
not just
to to succeed being a good businessman
or to get money and because uh in every
business the main reason or the main
goal of business is making money in the
media business making money is not the
main goal it's uh making money by but uh
the the core or the main goal or main uh
aim of this uh kind of business is uh
say uh telling the truth and um
informing people so in order to inform
people you don't just need a director a
head manager and other uh staff like all
other businesses in their structure have
but in media business you also need the
uh Editor in Chief which is responsible
for every word that is uh written in the
news newspaper for example if it's if
the business prints out the newspaper
the editor and chief is responsible for
every word that journalists put in paper
to be correct the truth and to be the
exact one that will be delivered to the
citizens also in the J uh in the uh
broadcasting journalism Editor in Chief
is that guy responsible for everything
that is produced and broadcasted in the
TV so you in this in our uh business the
organizational structure is the
director uh head manager editorinchief
editors and
journalists knowing that this particular
business the media business is not
really easy to manage uh do you feel
that you have to deal with uh much
competition in your field um being a
journalist for more than 20 years make
you confident of uh dealing with uh any
obstacle any barrier that appears in
your way and you always fight to be the
best one on the market and always you
fight to to tell uh the truth because
your readers your viewers or people that
will evaluate at the end but you are the
not the only one and we are not the only
one in this uh Market we have a good
competition we have a lot of other
Medias that are competing in the same
Market uh is a small country and at
least we have eight National TVs and uh
more than 300 uh uh portals and 91 as as
far as I know 95 91 radio stations so
it's a big and it's aggressive
competition this Market uh but uh having
a lot of experience and uh having a good
staff uh have having a prepared
journalism with long experience and in
this uh field make us confident that we
are the best on this uh field and we and
we are working so hard uh not to beat
competition because competition is
healthy for this uh for any business but
to be the best on the market do you deal
with fear and doubt in your business
knowing that uh many you have you have
to deal with many people or you have uh
in your workspace do do fear that anyone
might challenge you or make your
business uh not feel that uh valuable uh
we have clear goals and we have uh clear
targets what where we are going and what
we are doing so we don't have dobs on uh
the way that we are doing business uh
there are fears there are always fears
if we are doing enough if we are doing
uh good in uh this field if uh we are
saying the the truth to our readers to
our viewers these are greatest fears for
us and we all uh as a staff as a all
people working on this media uh we do
the best to overcome any obstacle that
comes in the in our way uh but uh the
best way to deal with fears and dubs is
uh always going back back to the
experience to the examples that we have
gone through before and uh always when
we deal and when we Face something uh
new we uh discuss with each other uh we
look for best examples other people did
in this particular
situations uh I also totally agree with
you and seeing from my perspective fear
also helps me to keep me in my Fe in a
word or just keeps me moving because not
everything comes to you easily and you
have to um you have to overcome some
obstacles in your life but uh coming to
an end of our podcast I have one last
question for you uh knowing for your
business where do you see your business
in 5
years uh having a clear business plan
and having clear goals and targets it's
clear for us that after 5 years will be
a one of
the we will be in the top three
televisions in the covo uh we are
working hard on it and we will see
ourself uh having just not just TV
station we will have a marketing agency
uh and uh group of uh people working uh
for some clients uh preparing videos
preparing uh advertising materials and
and always a group of people
informing citizens with the truth it's
important to have uh in uh in our place
it's important to have a a group of
people that are investigating things
that other Medias are not doing so in
five years we we are working hard to
have a team that will uh do
investigative journalism this is one of
the hardest ways of doing journ ISM but
we are prepared to do it and we will be
one of the top Medias uh which has the
most prepared and most experienced
journalis journalist working on
investigative
journalism and with that we've reached
the end of our journey into the world of
teen entrepreneurship whether you're a
teen or an inspiring entrepreneur
remember that with the right mindset and
support you can turn your dreams into
reality thank you so much for joining us
on today's episode of high school
memories Mr shaan it's been an
incredible journey and we're glad you
came along for the ride until next time
take
[Music]
care